late on the 23rd of november last year
34 migrants set off from the northern
french coast on their final journey to
england
by sunrise the following morning 32 of
them had drowned
it is the worst migrant disaster ever in
the english channel
[Music]
in the weeks that followed families of
the victims desperately searched for
answers as to what happened to their
loved ones and why they were not rescued
one of the dead was an 18 year old
kurdish man tuana muhammad his body has
never been found
we first met his older brother zana in
northern iraq last november
just days after he found out that tuwana
was missing
in the months since he has worked
relentlessly to piece together what
happened that night
[Music]
the families of some of those who died
have appointed lawyers in france and
britain to fight a legal case
and we can exclusively reveal some of
the devastating details of a report that
they put together
an initial report has been compiled
using evidence from survivors text
messages emails phone calls and the like
and we've got a copy of that
investigation this is it and it
seems to allege that neither the british
nor the french wanted to take
responsibility for the unfolding
situation that night
the report claims that the passengers
called the french and english rescue
services for almost two hours begging
them to intervene
but no one came
a few minutes after this first call the
french rescue services again asked for
the vessel's position the report says
the position of the vessel was then in
english waters the french rescue team
then transmitted the position to the
english rescue team informing them it
was their responsibility to assist the
boat the report goes on to say that the
english rescue team tried to call one of
the numbers given to them by the cross
grenade that's the french emergency
services but the tone of the cool
indicated that the vessel was in french
waters they therefore considered that
the obligation to provide assistance
fell to the cross grenade
it wasn't until 12 hours later on the
afternoon of the 24th of november the
rescue teams found the first bodies
floating off the coast of calais
uh
is one of three migrants whose bodies
have never been found
zany mustafa and pistuan rasool are the
others pistuan's family hope that he is
still alive perhaps in a prison
somewhere mistaken for being a smuggler
the nagahat bow but
foreign was trying to get to the uk so
he could make money for his sister's
medical treatment she has a serious
heart condition
again
just as we're finishing the interview
she collapses
we put the reports findings to the
british and french emergency services
the british coast guard told us that
they received over 90 alerts from the
english channel that night and they say
every call was answered assessed and
acted upon
the french coast guard
never got back to us
the legal report tells a story of chaos
on the water and on the land
that night 32 people including one
unborn baby drowned
and no one came to help alice debunked
sky news in northern iraq